our next speaker
used to fence for years
even at the collegiate level
so please welcome our fencer rachel
all right welcome uh emphasis on you too
please don't come at me with a sword
um hi i'm dr rachel chapman the
doctorate is in linguistics which is why
i have so many opinions on language data
and i am a senior developer advocate for
raza we build software to help people
build chat bots i'm not gonna be talking
a whole bunch about chat bots today but
i am gonna be talking about mistakes
you'll probably make with language data
that i've definitely made with language
data and how to recover
so a little sneak preview here's all the
mistakes we're going to go over them in
depth
the first one is that transcribed speech
is not the same as text data
so this one is particularly relevant for
me and my work with chatbots where often
uh people will train a chatbot with some
sort of text-based model like somebody
texting um and then they'll want to add
a voice component and they'll try to use
the same model for both and have a bad
time and there are lots of reasons for
this i've picked up a couple just like
specific points that you'll probably run
into
so one is that people do not speak in
full sentences um
a lot of the parsers that we use so to
take
text input and create or you know
perform a structure upon it
to put it in sort of a weird way
are based on the idea that you're going
to have text data is formatted like wall
street journal text data and people do
not speak as if they were writing for
the wall street journal
also punctuation is going to depend on
your specific automatic spec speech
recognition
platform what you're using to take the
speech input and turn it into text
speech includes disfluency so things
like um
uh and etc um and these are natural
everyone has them you have them even if
you think that you don't and they also
contain information about how the
speakers feeling how certain they are
there's a lot of rich inflammation
information and disfluencies that are
not available in text and will if you
are not expecting them when they appear
cause you some headaches
uh and another
sorry i'm having trouble clicking just
once uh another
big thing that's different between
speech and text is token frequency so
tokens are
words
usually in english we'll talk a little
bit about that a little bit later
and a lot of the methods of analysis of
text data are counting tokens and the
counts are often very different between
speech and text even on the same topics
so i have here some data from swedish
actually
and you can see the most common tokens
again in swedish in speech and also in
writing and then the frequency
and they sort of demonstrate some
general patterns of differences between
text and speech so speech tends to have
more pronouns i me we you us those are
the english examples
and also a more skewed frequency so
people will say frequent things more
frequently in speech than they will in
text and also text tends to have more
rare words so there's a pretty big
difference in the distribution of tokens
between speech and text
and that means that you don't want to
just take a speech model and use it for
text data without retraining and vice
versa even if you have a model that
works on some sort of written input just
because you've transcribed speech does
not mean that it will continue to work
equally well um and the big fallout of
this is that you're going to want to
budget more time for multi-modal work
either for developing completely new
models or for recalibrating the ones
that you have whatever those models
might be
so that's number one
number two
underestimating the amount of variation
in language
and the specific two types of variation
that people run into most frequently are
social variation so who is saying or
writing this language data that you're
working with who's produced it and then
genre and register so um how are they
communicating i'm going to talk more
about both of these
what is the tone how professional or
formal is it what is the topic that they
are talking or writing about um so for
example a bank means something different
in a velodrome well bike racing racks on
this side a little vice racing track
than it does in finance or
you know watershed studies the same word
will have different senses
and the number one takeaway from this
portion is that models trained on one
variety don't often transfer easily
so
very quick introduction to
sociolinguistic variation this is
linguistic variation that is
a reflection of social identity it
exists at every level of the grammar so
a common misconception is that accents
are something that only happen in speech
and that reflection of someone's social
identity isn't reflected in writing very
much not the case so
a couple examples uh a [ __ ] caught
merger which um i imagine most people in
new york don't actually have but people
out here in the west right i'm currently
do um whether or not you have a nose in
your emoticons so this is actually an
age marker um there was a change where
people went from using noses to not
using noses and generally older speakers
will use noses um lexical variation do
you call something a firefly or a
lightning bug syntactic variation so can
you say something like the car needs
washed or we stay at home anymore do
both of those things make you go like
that that sounds weird i wouldn't say it
that way um and then semantic variation
so the same word having different
meanings like lift you know to to
carry or um the
elevator equivalent in the uk uh torch
is it on fire or not boot boot of a car
boot you put your foot in um and here i
realize this is red green but that's the
color that the graphic was made in is a
distribution of uh second person plural
so you guys in the west to the north
y'all in the south um and then a bunch
of other variants like yins that aren't
on there
so that's social variation
genre and register
so these are again if you're trained to
model on one population uh
there is no good guarantee that is going
to work on a different population and
specific genres or registers the terms
are kind of interchangeable um you might
run into include noisy user generated
text that's a technical name this is
thing like twitter rada
twitter reddit facebook posts etc uh
phone calls or conversations
telephony study of using telephones is a
very like distinct sub-genre of the ways
that people use language
reviews a specific genre yelp amazon etc
the wall street journal in particular
i've already mentioned it it was a very
popular corpus it informed a lot of
early nlp work
and the specific one that you're trying
to analyze or use for your specific
project which may or may not overlap
with some of these other genres and
these are just sort of a sampling to get
you thinking about what sort of types of
language use your data falls into
so
this is kind of an easy one kind of um
just know that language varies and that
it will show up in your data
if you are building something that's
going to be used by a wide variety of
people i recommend socially stratified
validation to make sure that it works
across groups so if you know for example
that you know people from new york and
atlanta are both going to use your
product maybe test it with people from
both new york and atlanta because
they're going to use language in
different ways
uh and you know as with all statistics
find data as close to your target as
possible whether that's in uh who's
saying it or what they're talking about
all right third
over doing the text cleaning this is a
great one because my takeaway from this
is going to be you should do less work
and the expression that i think about
here a lot is throwing the baby out with
the bath water which means getting rid
of something you don't want and also
inadvertently removing something you do
want
so just a couple examples here where
text cleaning would remove important
information
this top one cheesecake heart eyes emoji
cheesecake
emoji
in one of these someone is really
excited about the cheesecake and then
the other one someone is really not
excited about the cheesecake maybe
they're lactose intolerant
if you remove special characters you
will lose that information which may be
very important to your project
also changing the case of things or
mapping things that have you know
duplication or spelling differences in
them may also result in losing
information so i love cheesecake versus
i love cheesecake all uppercase
exclamation point that person is
probably a lot more excited about
cheesecake than the first one
uh
also
you may not need to remove stop words so
this is very common um stop words are
very frequent but not very informative
words um and i'll show you an example in
just a second
if you are not using a frequency based
technique um like tf idf the f's there
are frequency the word frequency um
where having something very common is
going to skew your measurements
you should just keep them in you don't
need to remove them so pre-trained
language models that's what lm is um
like bert or gp22 or 3
or t5 that you might have run into
these do not remove stop words so if
you're using anything with language
models keep them in and just to show you
the type of information that you lose
from a moving stop words
i've removed the stock words here
so keep stop words using frequency based
technique that has
inverted the meaning of the c of the
first sentence uh pre-trained lms remove
stop words using need keep right so i
just removed all the stop words in the
nlt english stopward list it's a python
framework it's not as popular these days
as it once was it was just a benchmark
to use to show you
stop words tell you things they are
important and if you don't have to
remove them don't remove them
so again this one's kind of a nice one
um
don't do as much text cleaning only do
the amount of text cleaning you
absolutely need to do for the specific
method that you're using and it's going
to depend on your method um and as
always work on a copy of the data make
sure that you're not removing
information permanently i think that's
just hopefully something that everyone
already has in their uh
their heart and just like tattooed on
there
all right
number four
only looking at the text so um as with
other types of data metadata can be very
informative when you're looking at text
data but if you get really deep in nlp
methods sometimes it can be easy to
forget about it so who
is saying and writing this um i already
mentioned sociolinguistic variation
someone's social identity is going to
have a big effect on the type of
language that they produce
um and is this maybe say the same
customer it's been like the last nine
times in a row there might be very
important information in the fact that
this person is you know repeatedly
interacting with your system
um
when did they say or write it so there's
one thing that you can
guarantee when it comes to studying
language and that it will change and it
will change constantly and consistently
um
and also the world and the things that
we talk about change so um there for
example there might be worldwide events
that everyone is suddenly talking about
uh that they weren't three years ago
that has changed patterns of language
use and that your project need to
account for
um where how did they say or to write it
so on what platform um i write
differently on twitter than i do in
emails for example that's going to
affect the text that's produced is that
genre yes genre um and why did they say
or write it so particularly if you are
doing um task oriented systems like a
chatbot i'm thinking about chat bots a
lot these days um that's very important
that's information that you're going to
to want to figure out if you can access
and use
so just make sure you look at the
metadata don't forget about it um don't
go don't go so far down the the tech
space rabbit hole that you you forget
about the other types of uh information
at your disposal
and finally
anglo-centrism so this means centering
in this particular instance the english
language and i would say that this is a
field-wide
problem in natural language processing
uh the field as a whole has been very
focused on english since basically its
inception
um and with that comes a lot of
assumptions built into tooling and
trainings that you might have had that
that don't hold very well so for example
not all languages are written or spoken
so many languages don't have writing
systems or have writing systems that
aren't accessible in unicode um not all
languages are spoken signed languages
are an important group of languages that
are many people's primary mode of
communication
not all languages have big training
corpora
available more and more of them do and
that's fantastic
but even something like french is not
going to have nearly the order of
magnitude of training data that english
does english is very very data rich most
other languages just aren't
not all languages use white space a lot
of tools will be built around the idea
that
there will be white space in the text
and that does not hold
cross-linguistically um
so a lot of east asian languages in
particular just don't use white space
a lot of languages don't
use that says user don't use words as
the smallest unit of meaning so english
is very grammatically impoverished we
don't have a lot of
morphological complexity and this is
sort of on a on a global scale i would
say english is pretty extreme in this
regard it's very similar to mandarin in
that way
whereas something like german that you
might run across
or
athabascan languages of the pacific
northwest for example
have a lot of morphological complexity
so a single word may be extremely long
and have a lot of smaller grammatical
units in it so treating the word as a
unit of meaning
doesn't really hold very well
cross-linguistically
not all languages have canonical
spellings or stable spelling systems um
i mean this implies a that you're using
a character based or like a phoneme
based writing system which
i i would hope that most people have
encountered or at least sort of know
about non-phoneme based writing systems
um for example
chinese mandarin
or traditional or simplified characters
are a great example of a
non-non-phonetic writing system
and many languages are used intermingled
with each other um so it is
honestly like again globally a little
weird that a lot of english speakers
just speak english and like in the same
sentence it's all english um many global
language communities will you know are
very multilingual and will use a lot of
different words and together even in the
united states spanish and english
together is very very common so a lot of
assumptions a lot of tools are built
around these assumptions and they just
aren't true
but i'm not gonna i'm not just gonna be
like
know about all languages i'm gonna give
you some orgs and resources to um kick
start the work that you might be doing
for non-english stuff um also these
slides are available on my website so
don't don't feel like you have to type
all these urls now really quickly
uh baskahane is a grassroots nlp
community run by african nlp researchers
they've done work on
i mean not every language in africa it's
a very very linguistically diverse place
but a lot of different african languages
and they are actively working on
developing tools for african languages
so it's a great group to follow if
you're working with any of those
um if you're working with spanish which
i'm guessing is going to be a little bit
more relevant for this group
hugging face which is a nlp startup
that's uh
does a lot with machine learning models
has a community specifically for spanish
and a lot of resources that they've
developed that's nlp and yes uh
iso code for spanish
uh and then the um
i'm not sorry i don't speak spanish and
i don't really want to say this bad uh
but uh the university of the republic in
uruguay has a fantastic nlp group that
has made a lot of spanish spanish
language resources available on their
github and i definitely recommend
checking that out
some of them are in python but some of
them are just sort of
programming language agnostic and you'll
be able to use in your own pipelines
and my big tip is if you are interested
in a specific language that's not you
know spoken in africa or spanish which
is what these resources are for
i would go to the acl anthology which is
the collection of all the
peer-reviewed published papers that the
acl has published the acl is the big
research conferences for nlp and you
know a great repository of knowledge and
i would search for your target language
there see who's working on it see what
they're working on
see if there's any open source tools the
nlp community the nlp research community
is pretty good about open sourcing stuff
um yeah and uh and start your search
there
so
uh things to think about
most people don't use english
cross-linguistically in the world um so
just keep that in mind uh if you are
working with the target language that
you don't speak so for me
again again that would be most of them
um hire a language consultant to work
with you on that language um sort of
standard linguistics it's really helpful
in nlp particularly when it comes to
system evaluation where you can be like
hey um or analysis evaluation being like
hey is this right
does this analysis look right to you um
and budget additional time uh so
a you know a desire that people have a
lot particularly with chatbots is to add
support for new language it's gonna take
a lot of additional time just to know
that prepare yourself here for going
into it um it's good to do but
be warned
so
those are our uh five key
mistakes that i think is pretty that are
pretty easy to make in nlp again i've
made these i know a lot about socio
linguistics and sometimes i still get
like oh no no i forgot about it so
transcribe speech is not the same as
written text think about them
differently expect variation between the
ways that people talk and the things
that they try to do um
don't do too much text cleaning like try
without text cleaning first if it
doesn't work then like do a little bit
but you know be lazy with the text
cleaning
look at your made it metadata don't
forget about languages of it in english
and then a couple well there's a couple
minutes um a couple last quick little
tips to take with you and tuck in your
shirt pocket um be a little bit paranoid
i think most data scientists are
but don't don't stop doing that uh look
at your language data at every stage
with your eyes and if you don't speak
the relevant language ask your language
consultant to look at it make sure that
you know
your assumptions about it are correct
uh do as little as possible try not to
do like big transformations that aren't
necessary particularly if you're not
using frequency-based techniques don't
feel like you have to use the
frequency-based transformations
um modular flexible pipelines keep your
new components or any sort of process
that you're doing you know
write your functions make sure that you
know you have a pipeline again general
data science advice but also true for
language um
budget for better data particularly more
relevant data if you can't find anything
in your target domain and language you
may need to like get it and it might be
expensive just know that
um
testing validation and evaluation
run your tests validate your models
evaluate your system works in practice
again just general best best practices
um and finally don't reinvent the wheel
probably someone has already done what
you are trying to do with language data
so if you want to make it work then you
can see uh what other folks have done
and again the acl anthology is a really
good place to start
or looking at a list of nlp tasks
so
uh that's all i've got thanks for
joining i know this was a little bit of
a whirlwind
very high level talk i just want you to
think about things have them in your
brain and when something seems too good
to be true
be suspicious
if you have any questions or you want to
chat more i'll be here or you can at me
on twitter thanks so much
thank you very much that was uh that was
really great
and we are going to continue with nlp in
a minute but first we are going to do a
few more giveaways